*mellow drums and violin*
What you call love was invented by guys like me...
to sell nylons.
You're on a first date. Marry is the girl you want to really impress her. How do you make her feel special?
Well start off with some fabulous food...
a little fabulous conversation
What else fabulous John?
And end with a fabulous foot massage, for an evening of total fabulosity.
Look my job is to introduce your headphones to a huge drunk male audience.
Again? *meow*
My cat! *meowing*
Bad kitty!
*meow*
*screaming*
In all deference to the weeks Bob spent trying to develop ties with Chevy.
I think it's best if I bring in my own team.
*man screaming*
So he won't forget me.
Yeah?
This is?
Collin.
Cute name.
Jeanie.
Do you understand having you out here is the same as having no one.
He said it was a surprise.
A surprise? Well thank you for that, here's a surprise.
Wasn't he great?
He seems nice.
He can rap about anything. He was totally cracking me up on the bus.
Since when are you allowed to use the words long term in this office?
It will be 1973 before we're even.
Great so you have it.
No store has this version.
Now what do I do?
You get it free!
Let me understand. You don't have the video, but you're gonna tell me how to get it free?
Your activities last night have cost us this account.
What?
Go ahead tell him how you corrupted my account and my friend.
Well in a few moments I'm going to put on my Versace overcoat...
Get into my Mercedes...
Drive to my 5th avenue apartment...
And squeeze my girlfriends big fake boobs.
Look... I will apologize face to face, as horrible as that will be, but I think you're...
There's no reason to let me go.
Lucky for me I already have my dream job.
You're a corporate research analyst. *laughing*
Oh you're right my job sucks...
She can smell the Clio, Don!
Remember your first big ad?
She has her heart set on it.
I'll miss you too Pheebs.
And I will be holding you... right here.
I didn't expect to see you.
Megans in for a visit.
Hey, thanks for the subtitles.
Nice cut though... makes you look tough.
What are you doing walking all by your lonesome.
Just coming home from the movies, I didn't think.
Pete, There's nothing to discuss.
I like Bob, Chevy likes Bob, and if you don't like Bob... we can find someone who does.
Have courage princess.
What can it be? Three circles joined... two moons... and a crown...
I just got off the phone with UFC and they're having the Nixon boys stop by at the end of the week.
With Nixon?
No thank God, otherwise I'd have to move the piano out of my office.
Now there you are....
Yes there's that face...
That face... that somehow I trust.